ja ich kann nicht verstehen wie man als
wärs einiger das müssen sie schon mit
nicht so viel weniger ausgaben für
beach house komischer name versohlt es
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass wir da
ihrer partei dazu rechnen lassen denn
ein stück weit mehr kontrolliert
verteidigungsministerin in diesen
hunderte von millionen jedes jahr mit
militär als beispielsweise andere länder
kann jedenfalls freundlich auch nicht
kontinuität hätten aber wenn sie in so
kriegszeiten auf die idee kommen kann in
wie hier befolgten noch einmal leicht
sie haben mit der csu alle
dementsprechend muss man sich auch sagen
null ergebnis muss man sagen man muss
den urlaub zu fahren während die ukraine
einem riesengroßen haushalt mit mehreren
kultur lambrecht waren wir zu den
verteidigungsminister den letzten jahren
es wurde jetzt einfach mal so als
von draußen betrachtet aber in unter
hundert milliarden euro durch gehen da
uns ja anflehen dass wir ihnen schwere
sanktionen kommen und da würde ich
bürgerin habe ich mich das wirklich
gefragt so gegeben jetzt mal hier 100
seit 2005 also können die danach richten
solchen bedingungen greifen natürlich
natürlich gerne fragen viktor ein hier
finden sie schon in parken auch geld das
waffen liefern war sie im beach house
die rüstungskonzerne auch
milliarden los aber muss man nicht erst
ist doch so wenn bei einem die hütte
gestellt und die armee ist in diesem
man sparen aber erst einige das würde
mal überlegen ok wo die sika denn geld
sylt unterwegs wie ich gelesen habe und
brennt ja da bleibt man ja auch zu hause
beklagenswerten zustand weil er ist der
mich interessieren sie sind ja
schamlos zu die neben preise die sie
durch was muss man besser machen einen
finanzfachmann sie sind im
und fertig in den urlaub dementsprechend
das ist aus meiner sicht sehr sehr
junge da war dann war er guttenberg da
plan aufstellt nicht vielleicht eher der
finanzausschuss sind ja auch experte wir
unsensibel und auch instinktlos es ist
kriegen und wenn niemand da ist der sagt
wie kann es denn sein was ist das auch
dann war er de maizière da dann war frau
unternehmergeist in der bundeswehr als
haben ja erlebt und das meine ich jetzt
für ein symbol an die deutsche
ein panzer den ihr für 500 millionen
nicht so dass ich jetzt denken würde
das geld ich glaube man muss beides
ohne parteipolitische kritik wirklich
von der leyen da und dann war frau kramp
bevölkerung dass frau lambrecht jetzt
dass so eine verteidigungsministerin
machen man muss auf der einen seite das
das aber es verschiedene versuche
als verteidigungsministerin mein urlaub
verkaufen wollte den könnte auch für 250
karrenbauer da und die haben es
kein urlaub verdient hätte oder dass sie
geld zur verfügung stellen aber dann
gegeben hat bei der bundeswehr diesen
machen zu müssen es ist ein symbol für
millionen verkaufen wenn das gezahlt
irgendwie alle nicht hingekriegt die
muss man halt auch dazu kommen dass man
mangelnde lernfähigkeit denn frau
armee in einen zustand zu versetzen
das geld effektiv dann auch ausgibt und
wird machen dies auch und deshalb
in der kaserne die munitionskisten
milliarden flüssen irgendwie auf die
lambrecht ist teil der ampelkoalition
sie wissen wie haben das beschaffungsamt
einheit noch die wehrpflicht abgeschafft
versichern da so ungeheurer beträge ohne
und hat gerade schmerz verliebt wie eine
in koblenz da sind sag ich mal die wege
spur zu kommen ursula von der leyen hat
packen soll aber ich glaube gerade in
dass sie jetzt verteidigungs fähig ist
dass man den effekt merk
ministerin in ihrem eigenen kabinett
das wird die intensiv versucht indem sie
diesen zeiten ist es absolut falsche
und da muss man sagen das sollten wir
durchaus bürokratische monstrum machen
zurücktreten musste wegen eines urlaubs
halt mit kind sehr eingebracht am ende
signal zum einen unsere bevölkerung es
auch nicht ganz ausklammern vor dem
aber ehrlich gesagt auch nur die machen
in einer krise und was macht sie eine
ist es auch schief gelaufen aber
kommt so ein bisschen rüber als ob das
aber ehrlich gesagt auch nur das was wir
hintergrund dessen dass wir hier
zumindest verso und und trotzdem hat man
woche später wie ein scheingefecht
alles gar nicht so schlimm sei obwohl in
verschiedene andere themen
richtig sagt sie fährt in urlaub wie
ihnen als politik vor beschrieben haben
mitdiskutieren
er sprich im panzer muss auch die neun
das gefühl gibt es milliarden die
zwei flugstunden entfernt immer noch
ich glaube ich schon also ich nehme die
blöd kann man eins sein also ich hab
krieg herrscht aber noch viel schlimmer
gedacht wo ist der lerneffekt überhaupt
reingesteckt werden in die bundeswehr
monate schwangere frau die als soldatin
es ist ein ganz schlechtes zeichen in
nicht da waren sind und dann auch noch
die aber trotzdem
kritik verteidigen sie nichts was nicht
mit bärbel bas der spd
ineffizient gebraucht werden verbraucht
unterwegs haben er kommt wäre eigentlich
richtung der ukraine denen wir damit
zu verteidigen ist
bundestagspräsidentin also dümmer geht's
werden braucht es nicht eine stärkere
eher dass so etwas wenn diese krise ein
zeigen wir helfen euch eigentlich nicht
nicht weder dümmer geht es nicht sagte
so ist heute mehr es würde mir fern
so wie wir es können und das ist für
liegen große beteiligung als nicht zu
aufsicht finanziell finanzaufsicht über
victor du jetzt kommunikationsberater
gutes hat dann ist es hoffentlich dass
mich unverständlich instinktlos und hat
verteidigen ist ich erinnere mich noch
wir da mal mit dem stall wesentlich mehr
hättest du ihr geraten ins peaches nach
gut an den cdu-bundesparteitag war mein
die entsprechenden ausschüsse dass man
mich geärgert
für mich ist das ein symptom für eine
schön zu fahren nein natürlich nicht
fragt ja nach einem gemeinsamen spirit
sagt wir kontrollieren würde ich mal
erster als uns zu guttenberg erklärte
weil ich mal so viele politiker haben
genau wie die durchflüsse und abflüsse
viel tiefer angelegte malaise in der
um zu überlegen was man dem geld anfängt
warum wir jetzt die wehrpflicht
ärger mit ihren urlauben gehabt jeder
sind tatsächlich sagen jetzt mal als
das gibt's ja nich bisher dieses
deutschen politik die viel beschworenen
abschafft wir müssen nun alle standen
weiß doch was da auf einen zukommt es
bundestagsabgeordneter genau das
und alle genannten auf den tischen und
gemeinsamer runde der der
zeitenwende deutschland gibt es nämlich
gegenteil also ich beschneide jetzt
haben im zuge yoga er hat mir dass ich
bundestagsparteien wo sie sich
ist einige kennt es auch ich meine der
gar nicht die ist nicht angekommen in
zusammensetzen und gemeinsam besprechen
eigentlich meine eigene kompetenz es ist
nachbarstadt nrw da waren drei glaube
auch mal überlegen bescheuert und dann
den köpfen weder beim kanzler noch bei
ist nicht nur der regierungs aufgabe da
also so investitionen in der bundeswehr
kriegt da müssen wir uns schon auch
ich minister oder ministerin in
selbst kenne ich natürlich überlegen in
seinem kabinett ich habe auch den
das ja ins grundgesetz gehen soll und
ab 25 millionen euro müssen durch den
was für einer zeit war das gleichzeitig
nordrhein will aus nordrhein westfalen
eindruck noch bei der cdu also die
auch das grundgesetz verändert werden
haushaltsausschuss so das führt dazu
will ich natürlich schon eins sagen am
auf mallorca urlaub während die menschen
muss mit einer zweidrittelmehrheit
machen alle machen ihre geschäfte
dass jede größere investition 25
müssen die mindestens die union noch
in deraa ertranken also auch da gab es
schluss geht es natürlich auch nur mit
geld und wenn ich mir anschaue wie wir
daran beteiligt werden und das kann man
die spd ist wieder zurück gefallen wenn
millionen im rüstungsbereich ist dann
gab es natürlich entsprechende vorgänge
die diskussion über das 2 prozent sind
schon erwarten aber das ist ja nichts
die zu kritisieren sind und wir hätten
passiert also es gibt beschluss für die
in den letzten jahren geführt hatten
muss sozusagen es immer jeweils für den
ich mir sigmar gabriel anschaust wieder
beschaffung eines neuen jagdflugzeugs
dann war die union die einzige partei
zurückgefallen infor ukraine denken und
sie sich ja auch gedacht getan hast
ausschluss aufbereitet werden kommt dann
die das 2% immer wieder auch gefordert
und das war es erstmal so
einiger aber
erst in einer sitzung wird dann da
hat und wir natürlich in der problematik
schlimm es tatsächlich ehrlich gesagt
verteidigt dinge die nicht zu
entsprechend formell auch durch
insofern jeder weiß auch wenn als
verteidigen sind ich habe jetzt im daily
diskutiert das heißt uns wird auch sage
waren dass es insbesondere bei der spd
nicht weil also internen verhandeln wir
politiker in so einer phase nach sylt
ich mal aus dem apparat selbst
aber früher koalition lang große
telegraph einen kommentar gelesen der
als größte oppositionsfraktion natürlich
wert dass er sich an reinhold weise als
zurückgespiegelt das natürlich diese
hat mich wirklich gerissen da schreibt
zusteller sind die panzer der bundeswehr
derzeit mit der ampel ich höre aus den
dinge auch dafür sorgen dass anschluss
ein englischer kommentator man müsse
als sparbüchse benutzt worden hat dass
urlaubs insel der reichen und der
gesprächen dass das ja etwas ruckelt
sage ich mal eben nicht so schnell
schönen gilt es gibt auch andere ecken
man sich immer mehr still gelegt worden
darüber nachdenken sanktionen gegen
aufgrund des haushaltsrechts agiert
da sind ja höchstens noch die hälfte der
weil nämlich die anschuldigung je 100
deutschland zu verhängen sanktionen
das wissen wir auch alles aber was kommt
werden kann mein thema ist wir sind in
gegen deutschland nicht in russland weil
milliarden gar nicht nur für die
heutigen panther vor allen dingen gelb
immer raus das wissen wir aus
bundeswehr ausgeben will sondern da
so einer existenziellen krise und ich
übrigen nutzbar naja schwarz braun hat
eben deutschland nicht in die schule
verschiedenen anderen urlauben und es
vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere
ideen hat wo es geld unterkommen soll
komme in diesem konflikt weil
glaube viele haben es auch gar nicht
gibt immer eine skandalisierung auch
kapiert in was für einer existenziellen
und insofern
und uns ist eben wichtig die 100
deutschland nicht bereit sei die
milliarden euro sollen komplett für die
krise wir sind dass wir einfach ganz
energieimporte aus russland zu beenden
eine verteidigungsministerium hat man
also man muss da schon selbst sie sind
streitkräfte ausgegeben werden wir
urlaub verdient das ist richtig nur es
viel neu denken müssen und dazu gehört
auch bereit dazu wie man merkt das muss
und weil deutschland den alten stiefel
brauchen bessere beschaffung das was sie
gibt einfach das falsche signal es kann
aus meiner sicht auch so was wie
man selbst kritisch betrachten heute
weitermache in der analyse stimme ich im
gerade eben genannt haben und von daher
wie hier an dieser stelle natürlich
vergaberecht wie beschaffung die
nachdem der kriege in der ukraine sieht
zug bei den einer bei den sanktionen
politisiert werden und das muss man
bürokratie und schnellere schneller
sind hier in zukunft einige jahre hat
man vieles anders ich auch man sieht
allerdings muss ich sagen das ist
wissen denn wenn man seinem gegner eine
den willen als etwa um 17 prozent
vieles anders aber muss bereit sein
werden auch wir abschaffen und noch mal
natürlich eine krasse geschichte aber
solche solche vorlage gibt dann
gekürzt was sagen sie dazu
darüber zu reden wir sehen gerade was
wenn im ausland schon so gedacht wird
tja es wäre jetzt nicht meine priorität
das beispiel es ist so dass bei der
sehr spannendes gesagt hat steiniger sie
verwandelt er sich natürlich auch aber
wird sicherlich nur beim nicht nur beim
haben gesagt man es braucht geld das
weil die das ja hier ein bisschen auf
vergabe dieses einen panzers auch die
ich kann sagen dass ich im deutschen
habe ich ja gerade gesagt wir haben ja
daily telegraph so gedacht sondern es
die metaebene gezogen hat dann muss man
bundes nicht daran rütteln
schwangere frau im neunten 100 hätte
gibt überall probleme was das ansehen
jetzt das geld wurde jetzt
ja auch eins mal sagen ich meine die
andersrum ist meine priorität werden
bereitgestellt was ich mich aber
drin ist glaube ich insgesamt an der
deutschlands angeht und wenn die
manchmal frage braucht es geld oder
nicht gewesen hier zu einer kürzung des
armee was auch immer der lieben frau
verständigen aufsicht von leuten die was
verteidigungsministerien urlaub macht
hör ich bin sein 2013 mitglied des
braucht es auch besseres management ich
ministerin vorgeworfen wird die ist doch
ich weiß gar nicht wie man in sylt in
von der sache verstehen also wir haben
habe mir mal angeschaut wie schlecht
deutschen bundestags in der zeit haben
ja mitgekriegt was für enorme beträge
wir diesen etat verdoppelt gehabt von
nicht im zustand weil sie seit drei
eigentlich unser etat ist und wenn man
ein beach ausleben kann gibt es dann
monaten
es zum beispiel nehmen wir jetzt mal
durch beratungsunternehmen im
verteidigungsministerin ist sondern wie
russland vergleicht wenn wir jetzt gar
verteidigungsministerium insbesondere
bei von der leyen abgezockt worden sind